please do not respond to this email have
you ever gotten that from one of the
companies you've bought with it blows my
mind how companies do not track do not
monitor the emails that they send to
their customers they don't track the
account if in case as a reply so i just
made an order with a company that i love
it's a shoe company it's called vibram
they have these five toe shoes I bought
a new pair of shoes I bought some socks
with him total costs like 300 plus
dollars and I got an email today says
your order has been shipped whoo-hoo
happy customer then at the bottom please
do not respond to this email it is not
being monitored are you kidding me I
just spent over three hundred dollars
with you and there's no way for me to
contact you if I have a question or
problem why would you send an email to
your customer and not want to hear from
them it blows my mind what if I had a
problem what if I wanted to make a
change what if want to say thank you you
are not checking Iman stead of having a
great experience now it's a terrible one
instead of me making a great video
saying what a great company you are now
I'm slamming you how hard is it to check
your email and it's from customers who
are paying you money it blows my line
for those of you watching if you have
your own business I have some quality of
service check your email account the
only way you're going to stand out is by
having a great service level that over
delivers to your customers because you
will have millions of dollars to go and
spend on advertising campaigns last time
I checked you need people talking about
you in a good way to help spread your
message and you do that by over
delivering like crazy you need people to
come back you need people to tell their
friends you need people to say what a
great company you are you need word of
mouth and if you don't respond to emails
from your customers that's not a great
way to get started vibram you need to
service up check your email account it's
not that hard this is this is basic
basic level of service
and for those of you watching if you
have this as any part of your emails to
your customers take it off immediately
do yourself a favor check your email
account when customers are writing to
you I don't even know why I have to have
to say this this is just common sense to
me but I guess some companies are still
in the Stone Age here anyway let me know
what you guys think you like this video
please give it a thumbs up below let me
know that there are people here who
believe in service in their customers
leave a comment underneath you have a
question for your business leave it
below I'll answer it for you thank you
guys I'll see you soon